on voit bien où les risques de
contamination sont les plus élevés c'est
quand on se réunit dans des moments de
convivialité où l'on mange on boit un
verre on est debout à l'intérieur
proches les uns des autres sans masque
évidemment ce sont dans les entreprises
des pots de départ les séminaires les
moments festifs de fin d'année ça peut
être à la maison un grand dîner entre
amis une pendaison de crémaillère et
c'est mon message est très simple
jusqu'aux fêtes de fin d'année on lève
le pied on arrête on se protège et on
protège ainsi notre capacité à profiter
de noël beaucoup ont commencé
spontanément à le faire dans un esprit
de responsabilité cette consigne doit
être passé par tous il faut maintenant
la généraliser y compris dans la sphère
privée qui relève de l'esprit de
responsabilité de chacun des règles
claires seront donc édicté pour tout ce
qui concerne le milieu professionnel
y compris pour les cérémonies de voeux
de début d'année et qui devront se faire
dans le respect strict des gestes
barrières mais aussi dans les
équipements municipaux comme les salles
des fêtes pour ce qui concerne les
manifestations et événements en
extérieur comme les marchés de noël les
protocoles devront évoluer sous le
contrôle des préfets pour que les
conditions de consommation de produits
alimentaires soient strictement
encadrées et réservée à des zones
soumises au contrôle du pass sanitaires
le pass annie terre est un outil
d'incitation à la vaccination et de
protection face au virus que nous avons
été parmi les premiers à déployer à
l'europe nous l'avons renforcé depuis
cet été en l'élargissant à de nombreux
lieux en limitant désormais les tests
accepté à 24 heures et annie intégrant
dans les prochaines semaines la dose de
rappel ce qui renforcera d'autant son
efficacité pour passer cette cinquième
vague il est indispensable de contrôler
plus systématiquement est
scrupuleusement le pass
c'est la responsabilité
des gérants d'établissements recevant du
public des restaurants les bars les
salles de spectacle ou encore les
transporteurs et c'est moins le cas je
le constate depuis quelques semaines
[Musique]